You've likely seen this happen. A major
project keeps failing in the exact same
place week after week. When teams hit
this kind of friction, the immediate
instinct is to look at the most obvious
symptom. The project manager sees an
exhausted team and assumes they need to
hire more people. This chart shows how
that instinct plays out in the data.
While the headcount spikes upward, the
project delays remain completely flat.
The new hires are in the door, but the
expensive bottlenecks haven't moved. The
solution failed because it addressed a
surface level symptom. Adding more
people to a broken system just scales
the problem because the underlying
structure was never actually mapped out.
Complexity doesn't wait for you to catch
up. When we react purely to the most
visible information, the actual
mechanics driving the failure stay
invisible. Jumping straight to a
solution before understanding the
component parts guarantees that highly
intelligent people will spend
significant time and money fixing the
wrong thing. Escaping this cycle
requires analytical thinking. This is
the discipline of breaking a complex
problem down into a structured
evidence-based picture before you draw a
single conclusion. People often confuse
this with critical thinking, but they
serve different functions. Analytical
thinking produces the picture of what is
happening. Critical thinking evaluates
whether that picture is trustworthy.
Think as a mechanic diagnosing an engine
fault. They never guess. They
systematically separate the failing
system into components to organize the
diagnostic territory. If we apply this
to our failed project, we can use a
framework called MECE, which stands for
mutually exclusive, collectively
exhaustive. This illustrates the MEC
principle, sorting data into four
buckets, people, technology, process,
and scope. Every piece fits into one
category with zero overlap. Structuring
the problem this way ensures no
variables are double counted, preventing
root causes from hiding in the spaces
between. Establishing this structure is
a mandatory first step. It ensures that
hard evidence replaces human assumptions
before the analysis even begins. Mapping
just one bucket process using an issue
tree breaks a single process delays node
into branching sub questions making the
full analytical territory visible.
Without this teams lock on to the most
obvious branch and stop, missing
compounding partial causes. To trace
these branches down to their origin, we
use the five wise framework developed by
Taiichi Ono in the 1950s. Ono designed
the practice for the Toyota production
system to interrupt the human tendency
to stop at the first plausible
explanation. In a dense environment like
an assembly line, the sheer number of
variables makes it easy for systemic
problems to hide. We apply this by
asking why the project is running late
which points to a specific process
stage. Why is that stage an outlier?
Because the handoff consumes 3 days per
cycle. Why is it consistently slow?
Because ownership at that boundary is
undefined. Tracking a symptom backward
along its causal chain strips away the
chaos. What initially looked like a
massive undifferiated disaster becomes a
specific solvable fault. This reveals
the root of the issue, an unowned
handoff step consuming 3 days per cycle.
The analytical process isolated a
strictly relational issue. The workflow
map shows a clear ownership void between
the two teams. While headcount was the
intuitive guess, evidence shows the real
friction is a lack of clarity between
the people already in the room. Armed
with this precise diagnosis, the manager
resolves the recurring delay with a
single clarifying conversation. the
problem is fixed without requiring a
single new hire. This is the core
discipline of the practice. You have to
build a structure before you can
accurately analyze the situation,
carefully separating what the evidence
shows from what you assume. Analytical
thinking provides the structured picture
of what is actually happening. This
clarity is the necessary precursor to an
effective solution.